this is from oh paul and he's got a
question about secondary markets
hey jason it's paul holloman it's been a
long time since dinner
in chinatown it seems like 100 years ago
it was just february
so i'm an angel investor my question is
about secondary markets
how often do you take secondary on your
investments
when you do take secondary do you do it
at a premium or a discount to the last
valuation
and as a percentage of your investments
how often do you take some chips off the
table
that's my question thanks i get this
question a lot
um and i was in fact having a discussion
with a group of friends this past week
uh some of my besties i'll leave it at
that and we were talking about when to
liquidate
certain investments in terms of at what
price to do it a discount to the last
round
a premium to the last round the good
news is
you're going to get an offer in most
cases somebody's gonna
want to buy those private company shares
in which case
you're gonna you you might have a little
bit of negotiating room they may want to
pay 12
a share you could ask for 14 and wind up
at 13 or 12 50 or 1350.
so you're probably it's there's probably
going to be a market already that has
established the price so you don't have
to worry about that
what you really have to worry is at what
what percentage do you want to sell
so i'll give you some examples i was
able to take advantage of secondary and
calm
uh one time we invested when it was 5
million when it hit 250 million
i thought for the sake of the syndicate
we'll sell 10 percent give a quick
distribution
everybody can make a multiple on their
capital invested and still have 90
left because you don't want to be the
person who sells
all of their uber at 4 billion which
somebody did and uber's worth 80 billion
at the time we're talking about this
so you know that person got millions of
dolla that person got millions of
dollars
you know five years before i did but
they
missed the big run-up in uber from 4
billion to 80 billion so that would have
been a 20x
on millions of dollars in other words
tens of millions of dollars
if they had just held on for five years
so it's really easy to buy shares in a
company
you just write the check and they'll
cash it real quick
it's when this company's public it's
pretty easy to sell
and when it's secondary it's pretty easy
to sell as well
but the third option to sit on your
hands and do nothing
that is the skill of an investor knowing
when
to not sell is so important and man that
last double or triple can be the yum yum
that could be the yum yum that you're
waiting for so be careful
i look at it also as where are you at
life when i had weblogs inc and we got
that 30 million
offer from aol and i was negative ten
thousand my bank account
brian alvey and i were like we're
selling we're taking the money
we're securing the bag we're securing
that for our families and our extended
families
we grabbed the bag and we ran we ran as
fast as we could
with that bag of money now it's like
it's not so motivating for me to make
two million dollars
on an investment if i think it can go
10x
and get to 20 or it can go 100x and get
to 200 i'm sticking around
i want to see what happens so i am less
inclined
as my net worth has increased to sell
and um
you know the market is overheated right
now i think taking 10 20 30
off you will never feel bad selling
50 75 or 100 i think you could feel bad
and some things are out of your control
so i think it's good discipline to think
this
through and i think selling maybe 10
twice before an ipo sounds like a good
idea to me
that's probably what i'll wind up doing
in most situations
so whether it's robinhood com uber you
know any of those wealthfront
thumbtack companies we've invested in
data stacks
we are going to look at those and say
desktop metal maybe we'll sell 10
if we have the chance 20 before an ipl
but we'll keep the rest and i really as
a fund manager now
i want to have that moment like i had
with uber where we distributed shares to
people
that's a great feeling i don't want my
companies getting bought i want to give
shares
oh i was i was in some funds that had oh
that had square in it and they shipped
me those square shares and i sold
half the square shares but i held half
oh
oh square's gone on a run baby oh
i look at that square and i'm like oh i
got a million square
and i don't even know i don't even know
square had square cash
i love you jack love you jack keep
working hard